un péage urbain pour lutter contre la
pollution automobile
les péages traditionnels vont peut-être
devoir apprendre l'art de la
cohabitation le futur pourrait bien voir
naître d'autres péage à l'entrée des
villes ne financerait pas les autoroutes
mais aiderait l'air à se purifier
c'est une idée du ministère de
l'environnement son but tenter de
réduire la pollution automobile
mais les automobilistes sont ils prêts à
verser leur obole pour respirer de l'air
plus pu faut arrêter de s'intoxiquer
comme on le fait mais je concassé d'un
taureau de paillant il faut quand même
pas exagérer aux autres ministères de
rebondir maintenant sur cette idée un
peu révolutionnaire
[Musique]